nostalgia for the 1980s is still going
strong but the 1990s are finally getting
their moment in the sun
from cinematic classics like pulp
fiction and forrest gump to memorable
popcorn flicks like space jam
that 10-year span pumped out no shortage
of fan favorites
another notable example is the 1993
sports comedy the sandlot
co-written directed and narrated by
david mickey evans
the film follows a group of kids from
various backgrounds who come together
over their love for baseball
aside from their catcher's mitts and
only one ball they brought with them
loads of iconic lines and scenes that
came to prove that the sandlot is truly
timeless
the main protagonist of the movie is
scott smalls who overcomes his shy
tendencies thanks to his passion for
sports and his newfound friends
alongside the likes of benny the jet
rodriguez and michael squints palladorus
is hamilton ham porter played by patrick
renna who's best recognized for the
iconic line
you're killing me smalls you're killing
me smalls
despite his clear charisma and natural
presence in front of the camera and the
handful of other films and tv credits to
his name
porter remains rena's biggest role to
date it appears that moviegoers won't
see much of him in the coming years
either
patrick renna hasn't taken part in a big
screen production since 2016's fear
inc and he last popped up on television
for the netflix fan favorite series glow
that's quite a lot of time to spend away
from the camera leaving some to
speculate about whether or not rena has
entered acting retirement
by his own accord or due to lack of gigs
coming his way
while these claims remain to be proven
it's well documented that he's a very
busy man elsewhere
choosing to devote his time to other
ventures that he finds more fulfilling
than being a movie star
first and foremost rena has become a
family man in recent years and is
helping his wife of 15 years jasmine
renna
raise their two young sons flynn maxwell
rena was born in april of 2017
with liam james renna following in early
june of 2020.
for reyna's instagram page his kids are
his world and he takes his
responsibilities as a father
very seriously at the same time he
clearly enjoys using his social media
platforms to share all members of his
growing family with the world proudly
displaying the adoration he has for both
his spouse
and their children alike surely when the
kids are older they'll be delighted to
know how much of a presence their father
has in modern pop culture
after all renna certainly isn't one to
hide his past especially his time as ham
porter
speaking of rena's nostalgia for his
youth when he's not pitching in around
the house or
lending his acting talents to screens
big and small he's putting time and
effort into his youtube variety show
you're killing me with patrick renna
kicking off in early 2020 the program
originated as a
passion project for him and his group of
friends but became so much more once the
covet 19 pandemic took hold
in a fox interview renna explains how
your killing me came to be
and the unintended upside of starting it
in the midst of quarantine
he had planned to launch the series
pre-pandemic but he and his friends
quickly realized it would be a great way
to stay connected during lockdowns and
to provide some entertainment for others
who were similarly stuck in their homes
the channel grew fairly quickly and
amassed thousands of subscribers in a
relatively short amount of time thanks
in part due to a reunion of the samlot
cast
rena has also spoken on the content of
your killing me and why it's an overall
great thing for viewers in addition to
himself and his longtime friends
he said growing up in the 90s i realized
that i was a part of a lot of people's
nostalgia
but i missed out on my own so this is an
opportunity for us to share those
experiences
and talk about our time on those sets
patrick renna's performance as ham in
the sandlot will live on for generations
to come
and even though he isn't a prolific
media presence in 2021 he seems
genuinely happy
unlike a baseball signed by the great
babe ruth that's something you can't put
a price on
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you